.
* Musik aus dem Autoradio *
# You can get it if you really want.
Ich hatte nie das Gefühl,
jemand Spezielles zu sein.
Ich bin weder speziell intelligent,
noch speziell begabt
in gewissen Dingen.
Ich stamme nicht
aus einem begüterten Elternhaus
und sich sehe nicht aus
wie Brad Pitt.
Meine Erwartungen
waren eher etwas limitiert.
Und schau! What happened?
Es ist wirklich sehr viel Gutes
passiert in meinem Leben.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Es wirkt unglaubwürdig,
nicht souverän.
Das ist unser neuer Chef?
Einen Sender zu eröffnen macht
mehr Spass als eine Schliessung.
Wir möchten allen herzlich danken,
die von Anfang an dabei waren.
(Alle) # Radio 24!
# Radio 24!
Das Resultat ist recht erschreckend.
How many Syrian tanks did you hit?
Das wäre es gewesen.
Meine Damen und Herren,
haben Sie noch Fragen?
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Die Anfänge.
Roger Schawinski
wird 1945 in Zürich geboren.
Ein Arbeiterquartier, Kreis 4.
Vater: unterer Mittelstand.
Hie und da fehlte Ende Monat
das Geld, um die Miete zu bezahlen.
Es war eine bescheidene Wohnung.
Es war eine 2 1/2-
oder 3-Zimmerwohnung.
Sein Vater und seine Mutter
und seine Schwester Jacqueline.
Es waren
keine luxuriösen Verhältnisse.
Der junge Roger Schawinski
kommt 1958 ins Realgymnasium.
Und fliegt gleich wieder raus -
die Leistungen sind ungenügend.
Zwei Jahre später beginnt Schawinski
mit der Handelsschule
am Freudenberg in Zürich.
Ich glaube, niemand dachte je,
dass Roger später einmal
zu einem Medien-Tycoon wird
und zu einer ...
... weitherum bekannten Figur.
Roger
war kein besonders guter Schüler.
Er hatte immer ...
Er war oft im Provisorium.
Er kam nur provisorisch
in die nächste Klasse.
V.a. in Französisch hatten wir
einen sehr strengen Lehrer.
Roger war immer zuverlässig bei
les insuffisant.
Wer ungenügend war,
wurde gar nicht mehr erwähnt.
Am Semesterende wusste ich nicht,
wie ich heisse,
weil mein Name nie auftauchte.
Er hat das so ...
Er zuckte mit den Schultern
und tat so,
als ob ihm das
nicht viel ausmachen würde.
Aber ...
Die Tatsache, dass später
oft davon gesprochen wurde -
auch er sprach davon - zeigt,
dass es ihm nicht gleichgültig war.
Dann: Noch ein Versuch,
die Matura zu schaffen.
In nur sechs Monaten
will Schawinski dafür
den Stoff von drei Jahren nachpauken.
Man sagte mir, ich dürfe das nicht,
das sei unseriös.
Der Direktor schrieb mir:
"Das geht gar nicht!"
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
mein Bestes geben zu müssen.
Als das Resultat da war
und Professor Thürer mir sagte,
ich hätte die beste Matura
von allen gemacht,
liefen mir die Tränen runter.
Ich sagte meinen Eltern, die auf dem
Parkplatz in St. Gallen warteten,
ich hätte als Bester bestanden.
Das war ein turning point
in meinem Leben.
Ich wusste ... Ich hatte das Gefühl,
dass ich sehr viel erreichen kann,
wenn ich mein Bestes gebe.
Volkswirtschaftstudium in St. Gallen.
Schawinski fühlt sich unterfordert.
Spielt Studententheater,
organisiert den Hochschulball
und macht zum 50-jährigen Jubiläum
des Lions Club
bei einem Essay-Wettbewerb mit.
Thema: Frieden.
Schawinskis Aufsatz kommt unter
die besten Sieben weltweit.
Dann wurde ich
in die USA eingeladen.
Damals, 1967,
war das noch aussergewöhnlich.
Es war wirklich eine Einführung
in das Land Amerika.
1967 war sowieso das richtige Jahr.
Ich kaufte ein Ticket:
99 $ for 99 days.
Die gab es damals bei Greyhound.
So kam ich nach San Francisco
und stiess plötzlich
auf so seltsame Leute.
Ich fragte, wer sie seien.
Sie sagten: "Wir sind Hippies."
Das war der Beginn
meiner journalistischen Karriere.
Ich musste das
den Schweizern mitteilen,
da gab es etwas sehr Extremes.
Mein erster Artikel hiess:
"Die blaue Blume von San Francisco."
Ich teilte den Schweizern mit,
es gebe etwas sehr Spannendes
und das heisse Hippiebewegung.
* Folkrockmusik *
53 Jahre ist das her.
Dazwischen
liegt ein ganzes Journalistenleben.
Roger Schawinski empfängt
einer seiner letzten Talkgäste:
Fernsehdirektorin Nathalie Wappler.
(Leise) Okay.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Nicht weglaufen, dich braucht es!
- Ich muss Badges holen.
1 Sek.!
- Gut.
Hoi!- Hallo!
- Hallo.
Hallo, sind alle da?
Alles klar?
Na?
- (Mann) Ja.
Du auch? Du auch? Du auch? Beni?
- Ja?
Wir machen alles anders,
das ist ja klar.
Nein, so wie ich es dachte,
ist es zu komplex.
Ich mache die Reihenfolge.
Es ist einfach ...
Das Absturzrisiko
ist zu gross.
Oh my God!
Die 336. Sendung.
Die Schwierigste?
Eine der absolut Schwierigsten.
Sicher.
Warum?
- Ja, ich meine, he ...
Die ganze Situation.
Dass sie eine Rolle spielte,
dass es die Sendung nicht mehr gibt.
Ich muss mich da
irgendwie positionieren.
Das ist nicht ganz so einfach.
Ich spiele dort eine Rolle. Ich muss
ein kritischer Interviewer sein.
Ich muss die Leute
aufs Glatteis führen,
damit sie nicht nur
ihre Schokoladenseite zeigen.
Das ist nicht immer sympathisch,
aber das ist mein Job.
So verstehe ich meinen Job.
Ich will nicht Everybody's Darling
sein.
Das ist manchmal
nicht unbedingt sympathisch -
weder für mich
noch für die Zuschauer.
Er polarisiert,
ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste -
als Journalist,
als Geschäftsmann, als Mensch.
Der Mann ist geboren,
um zu polarisieren.
Dadurch schöpft er auch die Energie,
die er hat,
um so erfolgreich zu sein.
Er kann mit vielen Menschen
gleichzeitig im Kreuzfeuer sein.
Er kann mit mehreren Menschen
im Streit sein.
Er kann auch öffentlich nachtreten
oder austeilen.
Auch an Personen,
von denen ich denke,
dass sie eher seine Wegbegleiter,
seine Freunde sind.
Fühlt er sich ungerecht behandelt
oder wenn er findet,
der andere habe einen Fehler
gemacht, dann ist er gnadenlos.
(Kurt Zimmermann) Schawinski
ist ein emotionaler Mensch.
Ein oder zwei Jahre redet er
wegen Streitereien nicht mit einem.
Dann ist das vergessen.
Man sitzt zusammen, trinkt ein Bier.
Jahre später kann man sich wieder
streiten, das ist eigentlich normal.
Oh!
Hallo.
- Hoi.
Nathalie.
- Salü, Roger.
Hallo.
Geht es dir gut?- Es gibt nur
ein kleines Vorgespräch.
Ich will dir einfach sagen ...
Ich möchte die eine
oder andere kritische Frage stellen.
Jetzt überraschst du mich aber.
- Also doch! Deshalb dachte ich ...
1968. Roger Schawinski
zieht es wieder in die USA.
Auslandsemester in Michigan.
Dort lernte ich Priscilla kennen.
Wir waren im Klub
der ausländischen Studenten.
Dort traf ich sie - eine junge,
attraktive Puerto Ricanerin.
Ich habe mich einfach
total verliebt.
Es war grossartig. Sie kam
aus einer völlig anderen Welt.
Zu Beginn unterhielten wir uns
auf Englisch,
was für beide eine Fremdsprache war,
aber es von Anfang an Magie.
Erst später,
als ich ihn besser kennenlernte,
bemerkte ich,
dass er sehr interessant,
sehr intelligent war.
Er hatte verrückte Ideen.
Er war v.a.
ein sehr interessanter Mensch.
Am Schluss dieses Studienjahres
verabschiedeten wir uns.
Wir dachten,
wir würden uns nie mehr sehen.
Ja, das war schon traurig.
Ich weiss noch, dass ich
am Flughafen sehr geweint habe.
Ich hatte das Gefühl: Er geht
in die Schweiz und vergisst mich.
Aber dann kamen diese Briefe.
Und diese Briefe von Priscilla
waren so unglaublich.
Sie rochen fein -
sie hatte sie immer parfümiert.
Ich war einfach hin und weg.
Ich musste dorthin gehen, ich musste
dieses Puerto Rico kennenlernen.
Ich weiss noch, dass ich meiner
Tante in der Apotheke geholfen habe.
Mein Bruder rief an und sagte,
ich hätte ein Telegramm erhalten.
Dieses Telegramm war von Roger
und er sagte, er sei unterwegs.
Er sagte, wann er ankommen würde:
"Das war heute, er war schon da!"
Ich musste schnell nach Hause.
Ich habe ihn empfangen
und ich wusste nicht,
wie meine Eltern reagieren würden.
Meine Mutter kam von der Arbeit
und dann war der Schweizer da.
Das hatte sie nicht erwartet.
* Sie lacht. *
Schawinski, 24 Jahre alt,
heiratet die 19-jährige
Puerto Ricanerin Priscilla Colón.
* Sanfte, emotionale Musik *
Nach den Flitterwochen ziehen Roger
und Priscilla in die Schweiz,
in eine Wohnung in Albisrieden.
Das Geld ist knapp.
Eine der Frauen, die mit mir
in Michigan war, hatte uns besucht.
Es gab ein Fondue.
Dann erzählte sie meinen Eltern:
"Priscilla geht es so schlecht -
sie lädt Leute ein
und es gibt Brot und Käse."
Dann haben mich meine Eltern
angerufen.
Damals war telefonieren sehr teuer -
10 Fr. pro Minute.
Sie sagten mir:
"Du kommst sofort nach Hause!"
"Wir schicken dir ein Ticket,
du kriegst nicht genug zu Essen."
Ich war nicht traurig,
weil ich wenig Geld hatte oder so.
Ich war verliebt.
Und alles war neu.
* Sanfte Klaviermusik *
Ich hatte das Glück,
dass ich Eltern hatte,
die nie irgendwelche Erwartungen
an mich hatten.
Alles, was ich machte,
fanden sie super oder grossartig.
Sie fürchteten, ich würde wieder
etwas Wildes machen.
Ich habe ihre Erwartungen
immer übertroffen.
Das hat mich gestärkt
und auch beflügelt.
Andere mussten
gegen ihre Eltern ankämpfen.
Ich hatte auf diese Art und Weise
liebende Eltern
und ich hatte das Gefühl,
ein geliebtes Kind zu sein,
wie meine Schwester auch.
Diese Stärke hat mich
über Jahrzehnte getragen.
Mein Vater war sehr klein,
nur 1.55 m.
Er hiess Abraham Schawinski.
Er konnte keine Schule besuchen.
Er konnte seine Träume
nicht verwirklichen.
Er machte sich immer noch kleiner,
wollte nicht auffallen
und nicht irgendwie
etwas Spezielles sein.
Ich empfand es immer als schlimm,
sich so verhalten zu müssen.
Das tut mir so leid,
denn er war ein grossartiger Mensch.
Auf eine Art und Weise habe ich
versucht, ihn zu rehabilitieren:
"Ich mache mich nicht klein.
Ich versuche, das Beste zu machen."
"Ich versuche,
auf diese Art und Weise zu zeigen,
dass wir auch als Familie
fähig sind,
gewisse Leistungen zu erbringen."
* Sanfte Musik *
Schawinski ist der erste
seiner Familie, der studiert.
Als ich aus den USA zurückkehrte,
sah ich in der "Rundschau" -
die gerade neu war - einen Beitrag
über amerikanische Universitäten.
Ich sah das und dachte,
das sei totaler Schrott.
Das habe ich ihnen geschrieben.
Es gebe einen, der wisse mehr
und könne das besser beschreiben:
nämlich ich.
Schawinskis Brief landet
auf dem Tisch von Erich Gysling,
damals jüngstes Mitglied der neu
gegründeten "Rundschau"-Redaktion.
Wir haben lasen und fanden,
es sei interessant, was er schrieb
und wir luden ihn ein.
Er kam zu uns ins Fernsehen,
wir redeten mit ihm und fanden,
es sei interessant,
man könnte etwas mit ihm anfangen.
So beginnt Roger Schawinskis Karriere
beim Fernsehen.
Ohne viel
journalistisches Vorwissen.
(Erich Gysling) Wir alle machten
bis zu einem gewissen Grad
learning by doing.
Die meisten,
die damals zum Fernsehen kamen,
hatten wenig
journalistische Erfahrung.
Es war selbstverständlich zu sagen,
man würde es versuchen.
Das wäre es gewesen.
Sehr schön.
Ich finde diese Hotelier-
und all diese Geschichten ...
Könnte man die nicht komprimieren?
- Es dauert etwa 3 Min.
Es ist sehr kurz und dauert
nicht länger als 2 1/2 Min.
Es ist essenziell, was er sagt.
Das ist eine echte Information.
Als ich bei der "Rundschau" anfing,
war ich sofort Feuer und Flamme.
Das ist klar.
Ich bin erster Linie
darauf abgefahren.
Karriere.
Er wollte weiterkommen.
Er hatte so viele Ideen.
Er wollte mehr
fürs Fernsehen arbeiten.
Er hatte immer sehr viele Ideen.
Er ist ein Mensch, der ...
Er schlief nachts und auf einmal
sprang er mitten in der Nacht auf.
Ich fragte, was los sei
und er sagte,
er wisse, welche Musik er für einen
Beitrag im Fernsehen nehmen könne.
Ich fragte,
ob er nicht geschlafen habe.
Er sagte, er habe geschlafen,
aber im Schlaf weitergearbeitet.
1972 - Südamerika ist in Aufruhr.
In Argentinien erwartet man
die Rückkehr des ehemaligen
Präsidenten Juan Perón.
* Demonstrationsparolen *
Roger Schawinski will dabei sein.
Glücklicher Zufall:
Reinhard Meier, sein Jugendfreund
aus der Handelsschule,
arbeitet zu jener Zeit
als Journalist in Buenos Aires.
Ich konnte ihm ein paar Termine
beschaffen und ihm Ratschläge geben,
welche Themen vorkommen.
Das war für ihn
und für mich ein Glücksfall.
In diesen Ländern
passierte unglaublich viel,
gerade in dem Jahr.
Und so berichtet
Jungreporter Schawinski
mehr oder weniger zufällig darüber,
wie Juan Perón aus dem Exil
nach Argentinien zurückkehrt.
Ich sagte den Argentiniern,
ich sei zufällig da.
"Was? Wir warten 17 Jahre
und du kommst,
und nach zwei Tagen ist Perón da?"
Wir waren alle wie elektrisiert.
Das war eine Riesengeschichte.
Er freute sich,
weil er wusste,
dass man daraus eine gute Geschichte
fürs Fernsehen machen konnte.
(Sprechchor) Perón! Perón! Perón!
Perón! Perón! Perón! Perón! Perón!
Auch als ein Jahr später in Israel
der Jom-Kippur-Krieg ausbricht,
ist Roger Schawinski vor Ort.
* Israelische Wortfetzen *
Auf den ersten Blick ist Tel Aviv
eine Stadt im Frieden.
Schaut man genauer, erkennt man,
dass nicht weit von hier
ein äusserst blutiger Krieg
geführt wird.
Das war etwas irr.
Man musste einen Offizier
der Informationsabteilung mitnehmen.
Mit ihm ist man am Morgen
von Tel Aviv aus
z.B. 3 Std. auf den Golan gefahren
und hat dort den Krieg miterlebt.
Man musste auch mal
in den Unterstand.
* Unverständliche Worte, Wind *
How many Syrian tanks did you hit?
I hit five tanks and two trucks
and two guns, anti-tank guns.
Mit der journalistischen Karriere
geht's steil aufwärts,
doch die Ehe mit Priscilla
schlittert in eine Krise.
Er wurde immer bekannter.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, dass
die Beziehung nicht so wichtig war,
wichtig war die Karriere.
Einmal sagte ich ihm: "Das hättest
du nicht machen sollen."
Er sagte mir: "Wer bist du,
dass du mir so etwas sagst?"
Ich sagte, ich sei seine Frau,
aber wenn das nicht genug sei ...
Dann haben wir angefangen,
uns weniger gut zu verstehen.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
er wollte eine südamerikanische Ehe.
Die Frau bleibt zu Hause
und der Mann macht, was er will.
Entschuldigung,
wir sind vom Schweizer Fernsehen ...
Beim Schweizer Fernsehen probiert
Schawinski etwas völlig Neues aus.
Ein Sendeformat, das es bisher
so nicht gegeben hat.
Wie viel haben Sie
mit dieser Aktion gespart?- 70 Rp.
Plötzlich hiess es, es würde
ein Wirtschaftsmagazin geben.
Ich war Teil
einer kleinen Redaktion.
Die anderen sagten: "Das machen wir
nicht, das ist am Vorabend."
"Vor der 'Tagesschau'
können wir keine Bundesräte
oder den Präsidenten
der Nationalbank einladen."
Dann war keiner da und ich dachte:
"Okay, möglicherweise muss man das
anders machen als bis anhin."
Nicht die Wirtschaft von oben,
sondern die Wirtschaft von unten.
Dann kam die "Kassensturz"-Idee.
Das haben wir natürlich mitbekommen,
aber am Anfang wurde der "Kassen-
sturz" nicht so ernst genommen.
Es war eine Sendung,
die man mal ausprobierte
wie andere Sendungen auch schon,
die dann wieder verschwunden sind.
Nicht so der "Kassensturz".
Die neue Sendung hat bald den Ruf,
die Dinge beim Namen zu nennen.
(Werbespruch) Feines, frisches
Fleisch, gesunde, saftige Leber
und viele natürliche Nährstoffe.
(Originalkommentar)
Das ist die Werbung -
so sieht das Produkt wirklich aus.
Setzt sich Ihr Produkt
aus den besten Stücken zusammen
oder daraus,
was im Schlachthof übrig bleibt,
was die Leute nicht mehr essen?
Wir reden von Tiernahrung,
Herr Schawinski.
Ein Tier hat andere Auswahlkriterien
als der Mensch.
Wieso zeigen Sie in der Werbung
etwas anderes?
Meistens habe ich das
selber moderiert.
Nur Fliegen ist teurer
als Taxi fahren.
So ist es jedenfalls heute
in der Schweiz.
Wir verglichen die Tarife
in verschiedenen Städten
im In- und Ausland:
das Resultat ist erschreckend.
Ich hatte keine Ahnung, wie das
funktioniert und war unbeholfen.
Schaue ich meine ersten Bilder an,
denke ich: "Gott sei Dank gab es
damals noch keine Shitstorms!"
Ich wäre total
in die Pfanne gehauen worden.
Nach zwei Jahren "Kassensturz"
wechselt Roger Schawinski
vom Fernsehen zum Print.
Er soll der Migroszeitung "TAT"
neues Leben einhauchen.
Der Karriereschritt fällt zusammen
mit der Trennung von Priscilla.
Als wir uns trennten,
war er Chefredaktor von "TAT".
Er hatte gerade ...
Er sagte: "Du kannst mich
nicht verlassen, ich fange an,
richtig Geld zu verdienen."
Ich sagte, ich hätte ihn
nicht des Geldes wegen geheiratet,
dann könne ich jetzt auch weggehen.
Aber er war froh.
Es war eine komische Sache.
Ich musste den Schritt machen,
aber es war das,
was er eigentlich auch wollte:
Er wollte wieder frei sein.
Ich war zu jung. Ich hatte zwar das
Gefühl, das sei toll und wunderbar.
Ich war noch neugierig -
aufs Leben, auf neue Erfahrungen,
vielleicht auf andere Frauen.
Wir liessen uns scheiden.
Es war eine sehr schöne Scheidung.
Geld gab es keines und das,
was ich hatte, gab ich ihr - alles.
Es gab keine Kinder, keinen Streit.
Als wir
aus dem Bezirksgebäude liefen,
haben wir uns gegenseitig
noch ein Geschenk gemacht.
Er schenkte mir eine Palme,
ich ihm ein Transistorradio.
Beides wollten wir immer schon.
Bei der "TAT", die der Migros gehört,
will Schawinski an den Erfolg
des "Kassensturz" anknüpfen
und eine Zeitung für Konsumenten
machen.
Das Team ist jung und die Vorlaufzeit
mit vier Monaten knapp.
Doch der junge Chefredaktor
setzt sich hohe Ziele.
Schawinski wollte etwas bewegen.
Er wollte - nachdem er
beim "Kassensturz" war - zeigen,
dass er auch Zeitung kann.
Wir wollten wirklich den
Schweizer Zeitungsmarkt aufmischen.
Am 4. April 1977
erscheint die erste neue "TAT".
(Mann) Ich habe sie auch.
Als junger Journalist
merkte ich zum ersten Mal,
was Hyperaktivismus bedeutet.
Er war ein Chef,
der von frühmorgens bis spätabends
ununterbrochen von Büro zu Büro
unterwegs war und sagte:
"Das ist super!"
Von der etwa 40-köpfigen Redaktion
sind später etwa 12-15
Chefredaktoren geworden.
Ich glaube, Schawinski
hatte schon eine Nase dafür,
um aus den jungen Journalisten
zwischen 30-35 Jahren
die Talente herauszupicken.
Nach gutem Start stagniert
die Auflage der "TAT" bei 70'000
und die Werbeeinnahmen bleiben aus.
Eineinhalb Jahre nach der Lancierung
steht die Zeitung vor dem Aus.
Das Blatt machte ziemlich schnell
12 Mio. Fr. Verlust.
Das war auch
für die Migros eine Summe, die ...
... auch für das orange M
zu einem Problem wurde.
Zudem gab es
auch ein politisches Problem.
Schawinski machte
eine stark linke Zeitung.
Nicht nur er, wir auch.
Man darf nicht vergessen:
Die Migros hatte damals
noch eine eigene Partei.
Sie hiess Landesring. Das war eher
eine bürgerliche Partei.
Das führte relativ schnell
zu politischen Spannungen
zwischen der Zeitung und der Migros.
Probleme
machten die Leute der Migros.
Die Migros-Chefs
fanden es nicht lässig,
dass wir z.T.
aggressiven Journalismus machten.
Chefredaktor Schawinski
verweigert sich Kurskorrektur
und Sparmassnahmen - er muss gehen.
Die Redaktion streikt
nach Schawinskis Entlassung,
doch die "TAT"
ist nicht mehr zu retten.
Am 25. September 1978 stellt
die Migros ihre Tageszeitung ein.
* Breite, düstere Klänge *
Nach der "TAT" nimmt Schawinski eine
Auszeit auf der Karibikinsel Grenada.
Und kommt dort auf die Idee, die sein
Leben prägen wird wie keine andere.
* Abenteuerliche Klänge *
An einem Morgen
gab es auf Grenada eine Revolution.
Als Schweizer Journalist
erlebt man das nicht jeden Tag.
Ich musste das erleben
und fragte, wo sie stattfindet.
Sie sagten, im Radiostudio.
Ich ging dann
in dieses kleine Radiostudio.
Die jungen Revolutionäre waren dort.
Sie sagten, man müsse das Radio, die
öffentliche Meinung, kontrollieren,
so habe man die Macht.
Sie zogen diese Revolution
auch durch.
Dann machte es klick.
Ich war ziemlich ausgeschlafen
nach der Zeit in der Karibik, wach.
So hatte ich den Gedanken.
Jeder andere hätte das auch gekonnt.
Es war keine Kunst:
Ich sah, was jeder sehen konnte.
Doch ich zog
meine Schlussfolgerungen daraus.
Ich nahm einfach
eine Schweizer Karte und sah:
Das Tessin geht weit runter,
links und rechts ein Tal.
Nur das östliche Tal kam infrage.
Und es gab nur eine Bergbahn.
Sie ging zum Pizzo Groppera.
Damit war es das Einfachste
der Welt, das zu finden.
Am nächsten Tag fuhr ich hin
und schaute es mir an.
Ich fragte, wem die Bergbahn gehört,
wann ich den treffen kann.
So fing das Ganze an.
Im Mai fuhr ich
zum ersten Mal auf den Berg.
Innerhalb von drei, vier Monaten
musste man das aufstellen -
auf 3'000 m.
Schawinski findet einen Investor
und lässt für die Sendeanlage
eine Kaverne in den Berg sprengen.
Die Antenne selbst
ist ein 30 t schweres Stahlungetüm.
Technisch war es absoluter Wahnsinn.
Alle sagten:
"Das kann gar nicht funktionieren,
über zwei Bergketten, Bündnerland
und Glarnerland, 120 km."
Alle Techniker sagten,
das gehe nicht.
Aber ich fand einen: James Matter.
Er war halb Genie, halb wahnsinnig.
Er versuchte es,
und dank ihm klappte es -
mit dem stärksten UKW-Sender
der Welt,
einer Riesenantenne
mit einem Winkel von nur 14°.
So schickten wir das Signal
Richtung Zürich.
Wir wussten: 90-95 %
unserer Leistung wird nie ankommen,
sondern an den Bergen abprallen.
Doch der Rest reichte dann,
um die Schweizer Medienlandschaft
zu verändern.
Das war
ein wahnsinniges Vabanquespiel,
v.a. technisch.
Schawinskis Sender ist eine
von 3'000 Radiostationen in Italien.
Aber die einzige,
die über die Alpen bis nach Zürich
und darüber hinaus senden kann.
Am 28. November 1979
nimmt Radio 24 den Betrieb auf.
Illegal,
wie man im Eidg. Verkehrs- und
Energiewirtschaftsdepartement findet.
Der erste Schliessungsbefehl
lässt keinen Monat auf sich warten.
Doch die Radio-24-Hörer
leisten Widerstand.
Deshalb sind wir hier.
- Was wollen Sie tun?
Wir sind freie Bürger
in einem freien Staat
und möchten hören, was uns passt.
Wir fragen die Behörden nicht,
was wir hören sollen,
und lassen uns nichts vorschreiben.
Kennen Sie einander?
- (Alle) Nein.
Sie sind rein zufällig alle hier?
- (Alle) Ja.
Wir sind auch verzweifelt,
muss man sagen.
Wieso?
Weil uns nur noch eine Radiostation
interessiert: Radio 24.
Auf den ganzen restlichen Bruch
können wir verzichten.
Es brach wie eine Sturzwelle
über uns ein:
Tausende Briefe
innert wenigen Tagen.
Plötzlich
hatten wir eine Hörergemeinde.
Menschen, die 50 Jahre lang
an der Brust der SRG genährt wurden,
kamen plötzlich zu uns.
Innert weniger Tage unterschreiben
200'000 Personen eine Petition
gegen die Schliessung von Radio 24.
Wunderbar!
Am 29. Dezember bringt Schawinski
die Unterschriften
in Begleitung von 5'000 Radio-24-Fans
nach Bern.
* Melodie aus vielen Kehlen *
# Radio 24, Radio 24,
# Radio 24, Ra...
Es lief einem
kalt den Rücken runter.
Es war unglaublich,
was dort passierte.
Ich konnte es kaum glauben.
Solche Emotionen
erlebte ich vor- oder nachher nie.
Die italienischen Behörden wollen
den Sender trotzdem abschalten.
Als sie allerdings
am 4. Januar versuchen,
das Radio-24-Studio in Cernobbio
bei Como zu schliessen,
müssen sie unverrichteter Dinge
wieder abziehen.
Die extra aus der Schweiz
angereisten Anhänger
verzeichnen einen Etappensieg.
Der Streit zieht sich über Jahre hin.
Radio 24 wird zwischen 1980 und 1981
dreimal geschlossen
und wieder geöffnet.
Diese Rückschläge waren wichtig.
Ich konnte mich
immer wieder erholen.
Ich hatte nie das Gefühl,
ich gehe ganz unter.
Wenn der Sender geschlossen war,
oder kurz vor der Schliessung stand,
waren alle Mitarbeiter
total deprimiert,
sassen im verbarrikadierten Studio
in Cernobbio.
Ich hatte immer das Gefühl:
So schlimm wie sie sagen,
kann es gar nicht sein.
Meine Aufgabe war,
eine Lösung zu finden.
Auch wenn es nur
1 % Wahrscheinlichkeit gab,
musste ich das schaffen.
Darauf konzentrierte ich mich,
hatte kein Selbstmitleid oder
beklagte mich über die Situation.
(Sprechchor) Roger! Roger! Roger!
Schawinski mobilisiert seine Hörer.
Am 26. Januar 1980 kommen Tausende
auf den Zürcher Bürkliplatz,
um gegen das drohende Ende
von Radio 24 zu demonstrieren.
Man muss das ganz deutlich sagen -
Entschuldigung,
wenn ich so offen bin -
es ist mir peinlich, wenn ich
so viele meinen Namen rufen höre.
Es geht nicht um die Person,
sondern um die Sache.
Für die Journalisten war es
jahrzehntelang nicht verdaubar,
dass man einen Journalisten
so feierte.
Man machte es mir dann zum Vorwurf,
dass mir zugejubelt wurde, und fand:
Da muss etwas schief gelaufen sein.
* Jubel *
(Sprechchor) Roger! Roger! Roger!
Nach drei Jahren hat Schawinski
den Kampf gegen das Monopol gewonnen.
1983 erhält Radio 24 die Konzession,
um aus der Schweiz zu senden.
Radio 24 verabschiedet sich
in diesen Moment aus Italien.
Wir sind am 1. November
wieder zu hören.
Die Frequenz
wissen wir nicht genau.
Wir werden wieder kommen,
vom Uetliberg aus.
Wir danken herzlich allen,
die von Anfang an dabei waren.
Schon zu Beginn seiner Radio-24-Zeit
lernt Roger Schawinski
Ina Guiton kennen.
1981 heiraten die beiden.
Noch im selben Jahr
wird Roger Schawinski Vater.
Als Joelle zur Welt kam, zwei Jahre
nach Kevin, hatte ich das Gefühl:
Jetzt ist meine Welt perfekt,
nichts kann mehr schief gehen.
Jetzt ist es grossartig, wunderbar -
das Glück war übermächtig.
Aber leider ging diese Ehe
dann zu Ende, und nicht sehr gut.
Es gab viel Schmerz.
Ich musste um das Besuchsrecht
für die Kinder kämpfen.
Das war eigentlich der grösste
Schmerz in meinem ganzen Leben,
als ich mich weitestgehend
von meinen Kindern trennen musste.
Bald nach der Trennung von Ina
findet Schawinski zu seiner Zürcher
Jugendliebe Rachel Claire zurück.
Schon zweimal
waren die beiden zuvor ein Paar.
Nun, beim dritten Versuch,
soll es klappen.
* Sanfte, ruhige Klänge *
Ich hatte schon Kinder, sie auch.
"Jetzt bleiben wir zusammen,
jetzt wird das so richtig gut,
was von Anfang an
hätte gut werden können."
"Damals waren wir
einfach noch zu jung."
"Aber jetzt, da wir reif sind,
da wir Fehler gemacht haben,
gelernt haben,
wie man mit einer Beziehung umgeht,
jetzt ist es richtig."
Das waren wunderbare Zeiten.
Aber plötzlich,
von einem Tag auf den anderen,
war sie krank, kam ins Spital.
Sie wusste einfach,
dass sie sterben wird.
Sie war nicht verbittert,
sondern sagte:
"Roger, ich wäre gern
eine alte Frau geworden."
Sie sagte es auf Jiddisch: "eine
alte Katschke" - eine alte Ente.
"Das werde ich jetzt nicht."
"Aber ich wünsche dir, dass du
wieder eine gute Frau findest."
Die letzten Stunden ...
... haben mich ...
Während eines Jahres
war ich danach paralysiert.
In diesem Moment dachte ich,
mein Leben sei zu Ende.
"Jetzt kommt nichts mehr,
jetzt ist Schluss."
* Leise, weiche Klänge *
Das Trauerjahr, das es
in verschiedenen Religionen gibt,
ist vielleicht eine gute Idee.
Nach einem Jahr
ist das Gröbste vorüber,
wenn man das so sagen darf.
Dann ist man wieder offen.
1993 lernt Schawinski
Gabriella Sontheim kennen.
Es war ein gutes Jahr
nach Rachels Tod.
Ich wurde langsam
wieder zum normalen Menschen.
Sie stand plötzlich vor mir,
an einer Fernsehparty.
Um 1 Uhr morgens,
das war nach zwei Gin Tonics,
steht diese wunderbare Frau vor mir
und sagt:
"Ich war eine Freundin von Rachel."
Er war etwas perplex.
Wir sprachen etwas zusammen,
dann ging ich wieder zum Tisch.
Am nächsten Morgen wollte ich
diese Frau unbedingt wieder sehen.
"Aber wie hiess sie?"
Ich dachte,
ich würde den Namen wiedererkennen,
wusste ihn aber nicht mehr.
Ich holte ein Telefonbuch -
das gab es damals noch.
Ich ging alle Buchstaben durch -
F, G ...
Irgendwann kam ich zu S
und las Sontheim.
Da wusste ich: "So heisst sie."
Sonntagabend kam ein Anruf -
Roger war am Apparat.
Ich war schon etwas durcheinander.
Ich hatte nicht gedacht,
dass er sich
meinen Namen merken würde.
Aber er fand meine Nummer raus,
und wir machten
zu einem Spaziergang ab.
So begann es.
1996 heiraten Roger und Gabriella,
im Jahr darauf
kommt Tochter Lea zur Welt.
Das nächste grosse Projekt:
Montag, 3. Oktober - das ist zum
ersten Mal TeleZüri, guten Abend.
Schawinski gründet das erste
Regionalfernsehen der Schweiz.
1994 geht TeleZüri auf Sendung.
Roger Schawinski will mit neuen,
billigen Produktionsmethoden
im engen TV-Markt eine Nische finden.
Mir trat ein energiegeladener,
leidenschaftlicher Mensch gegenüber,
der sofort erzählte:
"Wir mischen das Feld auf."
"Wir machen grossartiges Fernsehen
mit TeleZüri."
Er zeigte mir
die kleine Hi8-Kamera.
Ich dachte:
"Mit dieser Micky-Maus-Kamera
wollen wir gegen das grosse
Schweizer Fernsehen antreten?"
Ich hatte grösste Bedenken,
war aber sofort
von Roger Schawinskis Fieber,
seiner Leidenschaft und Energie
angesteckt.
Als Partner holt Schawinski
Ringier und die Tamedia ins Boot.
Eine Verbindung, die von Beginn weg
unter keinem guten Stern steht.
Darum bin ich nun allein im Studio.
Ich war damals
in der Tamedia-Konzernleitung.
Da Tamedia
an TeleZüri beteiligt war,
sass ich im Verwaltungsrat,
zusammen mit Michael Ringier.
Das war natürlich ...
Die Verwaltungsratssitzungen
von TeleZüri ...
Meist begann Schawinski
mit einer Erklärung,
dass Michael Ringier und ich
keine Ahnung hätten, sondern nur er.
Das lockerte das Klima
nicht unbedingt.
Das waren mühsame Sitzungen.
TeleZüri findet sein Publikum,
ist aber wirtschaftlich
nicht erfolgreich.
Trotzdem denkt Schawinski schon
weiter: an ein nationales Fernsehen.
Allerdings ohne die beiden Partner
Ringier und Tamedia,
die haben eigene Pläne.
An den Erfolg von Tele24 glaubt darum
ausser Schawinski kaum jemand.
Liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen,
danke, dass ihr heute hier seid.
Für uns
ist es ein entscheidender Moment,
wenige Tage
vor dem Start von Tele24,
dem ersten privaten Fernsehen
der Schweiz.
Wir wissen wohl selbst nicht,
worauf wir uns einlassen.
Das ist vielleicht ganz gut,
sonst würde uns ganz anders.
Zweifel ist nicht sein Ding.
Er zweifelt nicht.
Zweifel bremst einen.
Ängste werfen einen zurück
und hindern einen daran,
mit Kraft vorauszugehen.
Das ist nicht sein Ding.
So geht Tele24
trotz allem auf Sendung.
Hey! Konnte ich das? Und jetzt?
Im Nachhinein war es wohl
etwas zu ambitioniert.
Wir hätten bei TeleZüri bleiben,
und das gut oder noch besser
machen sollen.
Roger hatte schon den Ehrgeiz,
nationales Fernsehen zu machen
und noch stärker
mit dem Schweizer Fernsehen
in einen Wettbewerb zu treten.
Tele24
ist eine Geldverbrennungsmaschine.
1 Mio. Fr. pro Monat
verliert Schawinski
nach dem Start des Senders.
Damals hatte ich
Panikattacken in der Nacht,
wachte um 3 Uhr morgens
schweissgebadet auf:
"Wie kann ich das überstehen?",
konnte nicht mehr einschlafen.
Ich merkte,
dass ich etwas ändern musste.
An diesem Punkt spürte ich den
wirtschaftlichen Druck am meisten.
Ich war froh, als es vorüber war.
Zürich: Roger Schawinski
verkauft Belcom-Gruppe
für 92 Mio. Fr. an Tamedia.
Zur Belcom gehören Radio 24, Tele24,
TeleZüri sowie weitere Unternehmen.
Schawinski nahm zuerst die Credit
Suisse mit etwa 30 % rein.
Er sagte sich,
dass er auch mal Kohle machen will.
Später verkaufte er der Tamedia
den Rest des Unternehmens
mit der Credit Suisse.
Das war ein ziemliches Gefeilsche,
das Wochen dauerte.
Doch am Schluss fand man sich.
90 Mio. und eine Bedingung:
Tele24 muss sofort geschlossen
werden, auf Schawinskis Kosten.
Ich muss dazu sagen: Einen Sender
zu eröffnen macht mehr Spass,
als einen Sender zu schliessen.
Das ist etwas von den Dingen ...
... die ich ganz ungern mache -
es ist fast brutal.
Es ist fertig, hat man mir gesagt.
In diesem Moment schiebe ich
den Regler runter und sage Tschau.
Meine Tätigkeit war weg,
als Moderator am Fernsehen.
Meine Bedeutung in der Stadt
oder Region Zürich,
wo ich Chef der beiden wichtigsten
elektronischen Medien war ...
Ich dachte: "Mal schauen, vielleicht
gibt es noch ganz anderes im Leben."
Und dann kam plötzlich eine Mail.
Noch in der letzten Nacht
von Tele24:
"SAT.1 wartet auf dich. Urs."
Ich schaute: "Was?"
Urs Rohner,
damals Chef von ProSiebenSat.1,
machte mir in dieser Nacht das
Angebot, Chef von SAT.1 zu werden.
Im Dezember 2003
tritt Roger Schawinski den Job
als Geschäftsführer von SAT.1 an.
Kein Mensch kannte Roger Schawinski.
Er war für uns
ein unbeschriebenes Blatt.
Es hatte im Sommer einen von ihm
geschriebenen Artikel gegeben,
in dem er sich kritisch über die
Führung von SAT.1 geäussert hatte.
Das kannte man von Roger.
Entsprechend gross
war die Aufregung.
Was gibt's Neues
aus der Welt der Medien?
"Schawinski löst Hoffmann
als SAT.1-Geschäftsführer ab."
Kennst du Herrn Schawinski?
- Nein. Du?
Nein. Schon mal gehört?
- Ja, also heute erstmals.
Wir haben einen neuen Chef?
- Ja, natürlich.
Menschlich etwas hart,
aber als Mediennutte
muss ich mich
auf den neuen Chef einstellen.
* Lachen *
Das ist in diesem Job so.
Jetzt kommt ein Neuer.
* Er versucht,
Schweizerdeutsch zu sprechen. *
Ich glaubte es nicht,
als ich im Hotelzimmer hörte,
wie er über mich herzog -
ich war sein Chef!
Er machte sich wirklich
grauenhaft lustig über mich.
Harald Schmidt verlässt SAT.1,
kaum hat Schawinski angefangen.
... weil ich Fan der Schweiz bin ...
Im deutschen Feuilleton war es,
als ob Goethe und Schiller
gleichzeitig gestorben wären.
Es wurde fast
die Staatstrauer ausgerufen.
Und wer war schuld? Ich.
Der böse Mann aus der Schweiz.
Das ist unser neuer Chef?
* Lachen *
Kann ich noch mal sehen?
Das mit Harald Schmidt traf ihn,
weil er selbst ihn ja bewunderte.
Er wusste,
wie gut Harald Schmidt ist.
* Applaus *
Wenn er wirklich etwas wollte,
hatte Roger wohl oft die Erfahrung
gemacht, dass ihm das gelang.
Und dann auf einmal ...
... diese Ablehnung zu erfahren,
das traf ihn.
Dass Harald Schmidt ...
... sein Kommen
zum Anlass nahm, zu gehen.
Doch der schwierige Start
ist bald vergessen:
Roger Schawinski baut SAT.1 um,
setzt auf Information
und einen neuen Führungsstil.
Es gibt eine Szene,
in der ich Roger noch sehe,
als er die Treppe runter
ins zweite UG saust
und in einen Schnittraum stürzt,
nicht etwa,
um den Cutter zusammenzufalten,
sondern um abzuklatschen
und zu sagen:
"Grossartiger Schnitt,
wie haben Sie das gemacht?"
Es ging um einen Beitrag,
der auch ausgezeichnet wurde.
Roger stürzte in den Schnittraum
und stellte sich dem Cutter
persönlich als Geschäftsführer vor
und gratulierte ihm.
So was hatte dieser Cutter
in 20 Jahren nie erlebt.
Das war typisch Roger.
Schawinskis grösster Erfolg
ist aber die Einführung
der Telenovela "Verliebt in Berlin".
* Emotionaler Popsong:
"Liebe ist" von Nena *
# Liebe sucht nicht.
Liebe ist, so wie du bist.
Aus "Verliebt in Berlin"
wurde ein gigantischer Erfolg.
Die Serie selbst
war sehr erfolgreich,
aber sie strahlte zudem auf
die Sendung davor und danach aus.
Auf einmal gab es bei SAT.1
eine Sendung vor der Primetime,
die funktionierte
und dafür sorgte,
dass auch die Primetime
besser funktionierte.
Auch finanziell
geht die Rechnung auf:
Der Gewinn springt innerhalb von drei
Jahren von 4 auf über 200 Mio. Euro.
Er war der letzte grosse Senderchef.
Die letzte grosse Zeit
dieses Privatsenders
ging mit Roger zu Ende.
Im Talk mit der SRF-Chefin
bleibt Schawinski
für seine Verhältnisse zahm.
Kein Skandal zum Ende der Karriere.
Danke! Tschau zusammen.
Tschüss, hey!
Ich hätte gern
noch weitergemacht, klar.
Ich hätte gern selbst entschieden,
wann die Sendung
nicht mehr funktioniert.
Ich glaube, die funktioniert noch.
Aber die am Ruder
müssen entscheiden.
Ich wünsche ihnen viel Glück.
Es ist schon ein wichtiger Moment,
jetzt da ich
nicht mehr Fernsehen machen kann.
Das ist ein turning point.
Es ist ein weiterer Schritt auf
dem Weg in die Bedeutungslosigkeit.
Das erwartet uns alle.
Auch das muss man irgendwie
ohne rancune hinnehmen können.
Man muss wissen,
dass man sich nicht nur über
seine öffentliche Rolle definiert,
sondern
vielleicht eher über die private.
* Tröpfelnde Klänge *
Madesimo,
das Dorf am Fusse des Pizzo Groppera.
Roger Schawinski zurück
am Ort seines grössten Triumphs.
Buongiorno. Sono Schawinski.
- Marco.
Roger, piacere.
Hei.
40 Jahre später - kaum vorzustellen.
40 Jahre! Und ich bin immer noch da.
Das war schon ein Highlight.
Ein Punkt in meinem Leben,
der alles veränderte.
* Majestätische Klänge *
Was ist es jetzt für Sie?
Jetzt ist es ein Monument
der Vergangenheit.
Dass diese Antenne
immer noch steht ...
In der Schweiz
wäre sie längst abgerissen.
Sie ist nicht mehr nötig.
Aber wenn man sich überlegt:
Ohne diese Antenne
wäre die Schweizer Medienlandschaft
vielleicht anders.
Dammi la mano.
- Sì, grazie. Molto gentile.
Ich denke, es ist gut.
Ich bin fast etwas verblüfft,
was ich alles erleben durfte,
tun durfte.
Wenn ich es Revue passieren lasse,
ist es fast wie ein Märchen.
Ich habe und hatte aus heutiger
Sicht solch ein erfülltes Leben.
Wenn ich es in den kommenden Jahren
noch gut mache,
schaffe ich vielleicht
noch den grössten Test.
* Leise, weiche Klänge *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
A. Werlen, M. Hachen - 2020